it's awful
i've never been through anything like
that in my life or i don't know he
smelled like a war zone or something
that was awful so awful
it's just horrible
[Applause]
i walked into the
dining room
and
then i heard the roar
before my ears popped
and
debris started coming through the
doorway and i just dropped down on my
knees and covered my head
my back door glowed in my face the glass
but we got down over our dogs
and we were both crazy
all of a sudden the walls caved in when
the ceiling caved in
blew me up on the floor trapped in the
corner under the dining room table as
everything was just crashing around me
and i was trying to get to my wife with
the other end of the house here and i
was covered with blood
my friend roberta was buried under by
federal
and her sister was on top of her whole
thing lasted like four minutes
i looked up
with my flashlight to the edge of the
house and i noticed there was no wall
there and that's when i told my wife
and i got up and
looked around in disbelief and the walls
were gone on the other side of the house
and this side you can see is
[Music]
[Applause]